now is Lord Lawson of course chance
former Chancellor's checker welcome to
you indeed what you see has been the
real difficulties and priorities for
this government I think there are two
overriding priorities the first is to
sort out the Scottish question and save
the Union and the second is to keep the
economy on course George Osborne has
done very well so far but there's a lot
of progress which continues to be needed
and so there's the two major challenges
in the major tasks ahead I think there
are others but those are the two most
important well I mean there are those
including Lord Forsyth who has been
arguing that the way in which the
Conservatives campaigned against a
Labour SNP pact as they saw it has
actually deepened the wounds and made it
more likely that Scotland will become
independent I don't think it hasn't
anyhow the threat which the Tories
warned about in the campaign was a very
real threat so they were right to
campaign on that but now we got to get
down to business in my opinion the Smith
Commission and the recommendations there
which were set out very quickly very
hurriedly was something of a botched job
and I think worried with the SNP there
and I agree with the SNP I really but
what we need here is a proper
constitutional convention to sort out
the whole constitutional issue it's very
serious but that is what is needed and
do you think that the answer is full
fiscal autonomy of making the Scots if
you like pay their own bills it may be
but there's also the other aspect of it
how do you deal with the question of the
the English being subordinate as it were
two Scottish votes in the House of
Commons from time to time whereas the
English have no control over what's
happening in Scotland and the more the
devolution full fiscal
it depends on whatever it is they more
unworkable that is and I I think that if
the idea of English votes for English
laws is worth considering by death in
fact the right answer because I think it
is bad for the Union to have two
different classes of members of
parliament and what I would much rather
do is what we did in the vaudeville
British did in the 1920s when were
independence conserve and evolution was
given to Northern Ireland was to reduce
the number of Northern Irish embiez very
significantly
and that has remained ever since as we
said I mean doesn't look as if at this
stage David Cameron is grasping the
nettle as firmly as you'd like well I
think he knows it's the nettle that
needs to be grass I think he's it
whistle hey if he grows to be too good
he might get hurt but there they has a
very prickly thing of this but I do
think that he's aware that this is a
absolutely major issue that has to be
tackled it's them the most difficult
issue but there are person says the
person jobs they need a look at the
person's a president of Canada where
they had a great problem with French
calendar which was kind of separate from
all the rest of of Canada and that was
dealt with in a reasonably satisfactory
on the economy a lot of people saying
well or something had up that the
spending pledges made in order to win
the election are not covered in any of
the plans that we've seen from the
Treasury from the Chancellor well we
shall have to see I suspect George
Osborne WA want to have an early budget
a second budget this year an early
budget now that he is no longer faced
with an extraordinary difficulty he had
on during the coalition because not only
is the conduct of economic bosses I know
will never easy he had to have
everything agreed by the Liberal
Democrat who's made his promise now not
to raise any of the major taxes v18 sure
I mean where's he gonna get the money
from property tax he's going to have to
as he said he was going to he's going to
have to find considerable economies in
public spending and raise taxes
elsewhere do you think there may be some
tact
in Greece's elsewhere but I don't think
he I think the emphasis is going to be
on savings in public expenditure cutting
public expenditure the other issue of
course is the European Union you said
publicly that as things stand you would
come out you'd vote no to staying in the
European Union do you think it's
conceivable that David Cameron and
George Osborne could get the sort of
concessions from the European Union that
would make you change your mind we shall
see I doubt it but we shall see and
there is incidentally Adam a connection
in my opinion with the European Union
issue and the Scottish issue what the
FNP have done very well is an exploiting
a feeling of Scottish nationalism call
it nationalism or patriotism becomes the
same thing and there and this has worked
to a considerable extent it's not the
main reason or maybe the but
nevertheless it is a reason because
somehow or other there isn't an
equivalent British nationalism that has
never been properly evoked and there
needs to be people want to feel a
belonging they want to feel strongly
about the the nation they are part of
and I think that the year the European
Union which is a kind of competing
political force has made it more
difficult to stress very strongly
British nationalism and that is got to
come to the fore it is right in itself
and it is is relevant to the Scottish
problems well your loss